avant d'être sélectionné pour cette
rencontre littéraire les professeurs de
lettres du lycée jean vilar de plaisir
ont répondu à un appel à candidature
afin d'accueillir l'auteur thomas béret
verdi une première importante pour leurs
étudiants
ça permet aux élèves d'avoir un vrai
échange avec un auteur de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui qui vit de sa plume et qui
peut transmettre justement une
expérience d'écriture et d'écrivains
authentique mêlée de la poésie à son
oeuvre
un mélange des deux genres de l'auteur
contemporain apprécié par les sept
classes conviés à cet échange de 30
minutes lorsqu'il va beaucoup marqué
c'est vraiment l'histoire de l'auteur
c'est à dire que l'histoire de son
grand-père qui a écrit juste avant qu'il
meure pour son petit fils ça m'a
vraiment touché sur sa très intéressant
de comprendre jusqu'où ils vont pourrait
inventer des choses
à toucher les autres gens par balle à
par l'écriture permettre une ouverture
d'esprit dès le lycée ne pas attendre
les master classes des universités
tel était le désir de cette rencontre
auteur lycéens ils sont précisément à
cet âge où ça se passe
c'est à dire si on les désigne
maintenant je parle pas d'en faire des
dépôts est un mais par rapport à la
lecture si on les désigne maintenant si
on leur dit vous avez le droit d'ouvrir
un livre et de prendre plaisir à lire
comme si vous alliez au cinéma où tous à
imaginer des histoires
eh bien on est désigné pour la vie et
les étudiants pourront peut-être mettre
à profit cet échange lors de leurs
épreuves de français qui se tiendra le
18 juin de 14h à 18h